la havane fait donc ses 500 ans cette
année et c'est la date du 16 novembre
qui a été retenue comme coup d'envoi des
célébrations qui vont s'étaler sur
plusieurs mois bien au delà de 2019 la
capitale cubaine a traversé les siècles
et les révolutions sans perte de ses
charmes
aujourd'hui la havane est une ville
vivante à la fois musées et lieux de vie
où en dépit des difficultés du quotidien
la musique est omniprésente et pas
seulement les rythmes de salsa recherché
par les touristes mais le mambo les
rythmes afro cubains et plus récemment
le reggaeton
la musique fait intimement partie de
l'histoire de la ville au portage
caroline popovych et christelle sivatte
[Musique]
à la havane capitale de cuba les pierres
sont vieilles de 500 ans
elles sont imprégnées de musique la
basilica mais nord de san francisco
d'assises construite au 16e siècle a
toujours raisonné des chants et des
accords de musique classique depuis 25
ans elle héberge camerata rognon un
orchestre composé exclusivement de
femmes
[Musique]
les 18 membres de l'ocs astres rap est
ici trois heures par jour cinq jours par
semaine
la plus jeune musicienne n'a que 21 ans
toutes font preuve d'une grande
discipline
chaque section de l'ensemble occupe une
partie différente du bâtiment
[Musique]
et
oui
la fondatrice et le chef d'orchestre
s'appelle own way de romieu
à 66 ans elle est la première femme chef
d'orchestre de cuba issu d'une grande
famille de musiciens elle a cru y ait
cet ensemble pour motiver les jeunes
cubaine
elle a lancé la carrière de plus d'une
[Musique]
[Rires]
nous aimons nous identifier comme un
orchestre de femmes unique des
pionnières nos prestations sur scène ils
sont esthétiques et techniques
c'est complètement différent les
musiciennes sont les professionnels de
grandes professionnelles elles sont
jeunes et moins jeunes
elles sont belles sexy et charmant et
elles ont de grands rêves musicaux notre
style vient la fois d'amérique latine et
de la caraïbe et des grandes stars du
monde de la musique
c'est absolument original et novateur
il s'agit d'une reconnaissance de soi
même de notre culture
une nouvelle proposition pour le monde
je voudrais pouvoir me nourrir encore
plus des différentes musiques des îles
de la caraïbe
aujourd'hui le basilic 1 est en pleine
rénovation
l'immense salle de concert est fermé
camerata romieu doit faire ses
prestations ailleurs mais tous les
membres ont hâte de retrouver cet espace
majestueux où les concerts ont ravi un
public conquis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lancastre le plus ancien de l'a20 ne
répète dans un entrepôt municipal situé
à st trop ravana bond à national de
concertos ce fondé il ya plus d'un
siècle n'a jamais cessé de jouer de la
musique
il y à 85 musiciens professionnels dont
lancastre tous ont fait des études dans
de grandes écoles
l'ensemble répète en contradanza de
l'assad soit la cécilia valdez composé
par gonzalo higuain directeur de 7 ans
castres pendant 30 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui igor accord à vera dirigent
ensemble à seulement 30 ans il fait
partie des jeunes chefs d'orchestre
cubain
[Musique]
c'est un fait assez drôle intel s la
ville a toujours soutenu ce type de
requête
ces ensembles ont été créés pour offrir
aux gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens
la possibilité de profiter de la musique
classique parce que beaucoup de gens
n'ont pas l'argent pour payer une place
dans des théâtres
mais grâce aux prestations gratuites des
ensembles ils peuvent profiter de cette
culture classique tout le temps les
certificats de reconnaissance des corps
la salle de répétition la bande
nationale de concerts temps c'est l'un
des orchestres le plus primé de cuba
c'est une grande fierté pour ses membres
[Musique]
notre orchestre est vieux de 120 ans et
la fête de la musique sans interruption
pendant cette période nous avons
toujours défendu les valeurs de notre
culture cubaine et bien entendu tout
type de musique symphonique
internationale et aussi les rythmes
populaires
le calejon daham elle est un lieu
mythique à laval situé à valence un
trône un quartier fondée il y a quatre
cent cinquante ans cette ruelle est une
galerie d'art à ciel ouvert ce sont les
oeuvres du plasticien salvador gonzalez
les mieux qui longe cette rue piétonne
servent de toile paul antiste il y à des
sculptures et une collection de
baignoires 1 castrés dont les murs sur
lesquelles sont inscrits des phrases
philosophiques comme celle ci qui évoque
l' empire de la peur et la nécessité de
la vaincre
tous les dimanches à midi l'heure la
plus chaude de la journée des centaines
de personnes des habitants et des
visiteurs se donnent rendez vous aux
calendes à asnelles c'est le temple
vivent des dieux de la religion yoruba
[Musique]
on
norma cubaine un mélange de musique de
danse et de poésie et la création des
peuples africaine est menée de force à
cuba longtemps interdite la rumba
influencé tous les genres de musique
traditionnelle à cuba
reconnu pour son expression d steam de
soi et de résistance la rumba cubaine
est désormais inscrite au patrimoine
culturel de l'unesco le cas du monde
dames elle est un lieu avec beaucoup
d'énergie et tout se mélange dans une
seule chose c'est là c'est la culture
c'est la tradition la famille est
originaire du congo en afrique
elle m'a fait connaître à la rumba
ça coule dans mon sens et quand je sens
que je suis très souple ça ne va pas
j'écoute la musique et tout le mal
sauvage qu iron est un lieu d'une grande
signification
il faut comprendre qu'à cuba il existe
la culture afro cubaine il faut
comprendre qu'il s'agit là d'une racine
[Musique]
les musiciens sont si vous l'invitez
chez les particuliers pour animer des
cérémonies rachel solaire fête son
anniversaire elle a invité ses amis qui
offrirait des remerciements au sein de
sa religion une robin rachel est protégé
par ossur la déesse de la fécondité de
l'amour universel et des enfants tout au
long de l'année j'ai eu beaucoup de
force de la santé de la stabilité et
beaucoup de chance et donc pour dire
merci pour tout ça je fais ce rituel
faire ce rituel est quelque chose de
sacré de très religieuse depuis que dieu
m'a donné mon fils il ya cinq ans
chaque année je fais une fête pour
célébrer cette année de plus il fasse
avec moi
au musée national de la musique
cette collection de tambour et d'une
valeur exceptionnelle
certains ont été fabriqués il ya plus de
cent ans l'enfant et leurs sonorités
sont copiés des instruments africains
que les esclaves ont reproduit à cuba
les métissages entre les différents
peuples du congo du nigeria et du
dahomey a donné naissance à des
instruments nouveaux
[Musique]
il y à des arabes qui sont ces tambours
de grande taille qui viennent d'un
territoire en afrique
dans le passé le peuple qui jouait de
l'ararat est arrivé à cuba
il a créé un instrument similaire ici
c'est en bourse ont tout simplement
fabriqués avec des gros d'armes avec une
peau de sion ils sont originaires du
congo
cette culture utilisait cette formation
ce sont les tambours de la santeria qui
sont les tambours d'origine du peuple
africain les yoruba s'il existe un
tambour d'origine africaine qui a réussi
son évolution dans le temps
c'est ce tambours bata hilla a prédominé
ait survécu et évoluer jusqu'à nos jours
à la différence des autres tambours
d'origine africaine qui sont seulement
limité aux besoins religieux le bata à
intégrer la musique populaire pas
seulement grâce à son aspect physique
mais grâce à sa sonorité
tatata c'est la sonorité propre dans
tamboura de pau des milliers d'objets de
toutes sortes sont dont la collection du
musée
l'établissement est fermé pour
rénovation et tout est entreposé dans un
bâtiment provisoire
ce livre fait partie des trésors du
patrimoine cuba écrit à la main sur la
peau d'agneau
c'est un livre de chant grégorien
utilisé lors des obsèques des notables
rédigée au xviiie siècle c'est l'oeuvre
la plus anciennes du musée
il y a aussi des centaines de milliers
de partitions de musique des
compositions classiques et populaires
il y à cette partition manuscrite de
perez prado de son fameux mambo numéro 5
qui date de 1949 et les compositeurs
continuent à déposer leurs nouvelles
oeuvres au musée les partitions qui sont
répertoriés par le musée national de la
musique sont à l'image de notre
patrimoine historique documenter le
patrimoine du passé aussi l'histoire
documentée du présent un panorama
général de ce qu est l histoire de la
musique à cuba depuis le début jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il y a des photos et des
enregistrements de grands artistes
voici bola de nieve ou boule de neige
dont le vrai nom est inaction ville à ce
compositeur a adopté le surnom péjoratif
qu'on lui a collée il a composé des
morceaux pour tourner en dérision la
racisme délieront de certaines
compatriotes
[Musique]
dans l'année l'otan invoque ap
fêter les cent huit ans de la naissance
de bola de nieve l'union des écrivains
et artistes a organisé une matinée
pointé à prêter ses chansons
[Musique]
il y a
nommé
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
pour moi il n'a que celui là est le
premier ambassadeur de la chanson
cubaine y avait en lui le meilleur de la
musique romantique et la musique lyrique
c'est la renaissance de la chanson
traditionnelle le chiplead ses chansons
la musicalité le ton ces interprétations
ça me motive toujours quand je le chante
ça touche mon âme partout à laval il y à
de la musique les chansons
traditionnelles résonne dans les places
publiques elles sont les métissages
parfaite des styles européens africains
et sud américains
[Musique]
dans une banlieue de la havane se trouve
l'un des meilleurs réparateur
d'instruments à cordes de la capitale
d'amaris romero utilise un fer à
repasser pour décoller les différentes
parties des instruments une méthode par
très orthodoxe mais efficace les gens
sont surpris ils sont surpris parce que
ils n'ont jamais vu ça il utilise de
l'eau pour séparer les morceaux mais la
chaleur ça décolle mieux depuis 30 ans
et dépend son mari raphaël
elle recycle les instruments ont cassé
pour leur donner une nouvelle vie ces
techniques de réparation sont si faire
fonctionner que les musiciens
professionnels lui font confiance
elle travaille régulièrement pour le
musée national
elle récupère aussi le bois des meubles
anciens
cette matière première est bien sèches
elles trouvent souvent des bois nobles
comme le bois de rose qui donne une
bonne sonorité aux instruments et des
années d'expérience et les règles de la
fabrication
on m'oblige à savoir à savoir comment je
dois posséder pour bien faire en plus je
reçois chez moi beaucoup de musiciens
qui me donnent des informations et ça
c'est une aide entre musiciens et
luthier 100 musiciens
il n'y a pas du che et sans luthier il
n'y aura personne pour réparer ou
fabriquer des instruments pour les
musiciens
[Musique]
dans son petit atelier en taule les
guitares commence à reprendre forme
après l'application de plusieurs couches
de vernis les 13 les lahoud et les
guitares sont mis à sécher prêt à être
de nouveau jouer
dj higway dont le vrai nom est innée
rodriguez a grands montets est le
premier producteur indépendant de
musique à cuba dj depuis quinze ans il
compose ses sons originaux dans son
minuscule studio dans vannes à saint
trop il voyagea partout dans le monde
pour assister aux grandes rencontres de
la musique techno
depuis les années 90 le rap et le hip
hop américain sont les musiques
préférées de beaucoup de jeunes cubains
[Musique]
les jeunes à cuba ont immédiatement
adhéré à ce style de vie en raison du
côté rebelle qui trouve naturellement
dans cette musique est principalement à
peine s'ils ont imité les rappeurs noirs
américains il voulait être comme eux ils
voulaient s'habiller avec les mêmes
vêtements qu'ils voyaient dans les
vidéos dj higway a fait des études de
commerce à l'université il a fondé son
label indépendant 2015 aujourd'hui
guan parents musique produit les jeunes
rappeurs cubain qui compose des morceaux
sur les réalités de la vie à cuba
ninon faut ni enregistré un tube sur le
quotidienne difficile des chauffeurs de
vélos taxis
[Musique]
c'est quand internet que la musique de
dj gouët et c'est en tice et distribué
aux jeunes cubains qu'ont encore les
gens savent qu'à cuba il ya la musique
rap reggae la musique électronique
et puis aussi des musiques alternatives
comme le rock'n'roll ou encore le funk
la jeunesse s'est approprié ces genres
qui viennent d'amérique du nord de
l'europe et de la caraïbe
ce qui est très important il ya une
réinvention de ces styles à cuba lors de
ses prestations dj higway propose un
style original sur un tempo afrobeat
il rajoute des percussions et les
paroles d'un rapport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d
[Musique]
ça ressemble à ce qui se reconnaît dans
la caraïbe sont reconnaît dans la
caraïbe dans notre identité en pleine
communal je pense on le retrouve dans le
bel et avec le nier / réponses et parce
que ce qu'il faisait au final mais on le
retrouve dans tellement de culture tant
dans la caille copines elles reviennent
this as même pas cette règle je disais
la prime
[Musique]
l'un des clubs de jazz le plus connu de
la vanne est quasi mot caché sur cette
cabine téléphonique britannique
là tu sors en iraq war bo a que les
patrons de jazz sept jours sur sept
depuis des années
les musiciens cubains ont crié toute
sorte de jazz fusion se soit lazaro
valdez qui a dirigé le big band de ben
et moret dont les années 50 présentes ne
sont jazz
c'est un mariage de jazz avec de la
musique traditionnelle les percussions
en taureaux centrale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la musique cubaine est très riche
rythmiquement c'est pour cela que les
musiciens cubains sont très bons dans le
jazz et la fiente 3 aujourd'hui on peut
parler de jazz un cubain afro cubains et
n'atteint pas ce qu'on emploie les
éléments afro-cubains parce que nous
sommes dépendants des noirs de la nation
directement de l'afrique
[Musique]
la case de la musique à un mail à man
ray surnommé le tout de la musique
populaire de cuba
c'est ici que les monts du de la salsa
cubaine
je viens danser sur les titres des
maisons castres et millau frias mieux
connu sous le nom de niño chante depuis
l'âge de 14 ans son groupe la verdad il
a crié il y a 6 ans c'est l'étoile
montante du monde de la salsa il se
produit en concert partout dans le monde
[Musique]
c
la musique est magique que ça faire
d'elle une compétition comme c'est le
cas avec le sport usain bolt l'homme le
plus rapide du monde sans doute mais
avec la musique c'est pas pareil la
musique c'est des couleurs selon le goût
des gens pourquoi elle minuit la verdad
et populaire avec le public
je ne pouvais pas vous expliquer
peut-être c'est le mélange d'une formule
nouvelle pour notre fraîcheur et notre
jeunesse
[Musique]
la vanne ne dort jamais la musique non
plus en dépit des alliant de l'histoire
qui ont marqué cette ville vieille de
500 ans les havanais se sont toujours
ressourcer dans leur vaste patrimoine
musical qui ne cesse d'émerveiller le
monde
[Musique]